hi there can you blink for me
good can you tell me how many fingers
I'm holding up before and what year is
it 2016 yes good and who's the President
Barack Obama who I jumped nothing
happens the way I imagined let me miss
us it over I live here
we travel into another dimension
[Music]
into other versions of ourselves do you
understand what we're on the edge of
here
it's godlike Larry my name is Karim
Washington I've investigated looking
into the disappearance of a teenager I'm
staying at this house is this the
missing person
you look like you've seen a ghost the
image just reminds me of a young man I
knew in Michigan it's all connected we
can get to the bottom of it
you're tougher than you look you're
kinder than the scene Oh
[Music]
and the voice I asked you to believe in
impossible things never once looked at
me like I was crazy
everyone who goes inside this house he
comes out cracked up or doesn't come out
at all you gotta open your eyes
I cannot keep up party this is not a
time to be brave
this is a time to be smart all this
beauty disability
that holds it together
what keeps it from dissolving into noise
q spots in 5/4
to
Wow
you